hi I'm Lord King David of iron Lords
podcast and we're bringing to you an
exciting new giveaway this giveaway is
like none other
we'll be giving away an Xbox Series X
that's right you heard me right the
brand new console launching from
Microsoft this year well this is how
you're able to be part of that giveaway
there's two ways to get your name thrown
in the head for the raffle one become a
member of the realm that's hit that joy
button hit hit that joy button you hit
that joint button down at the bottom and
you can become a member and also another
way is by becoming a patreon member so
you can be part of the realm as well now
this is brought to you by cat daddy fat
stacks a member and lord of the realm a
very generous person that's in our
community and this community is
beautiful so remember you can have one
entry by hitting that join button and
becoming a member of the realm and also
you can have another entry by being a
patreon now they said King what if I'm a
member of both well your name gets
thrown in the Hat two times so please
like follow us subscribe join or become
a patreon member or become both and your
name is in the Hat to get that Xbox
series X as to who did therefore you
sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
I'm sure that you will enjoy oh man
have a great day